[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur le plateau
de la grande interview avec aujourd'hui
jean-luc as bonjour dont l'ancien patron
de radio france qui continue de regarder
ce monde médiatique auquel il a
finalement consacré l'essentiel de sa
vie à un reporter correspondants à
l'étranger producteur d'émissions
animateurs présentateurs de journaux
derrière fans rien fait d'autre que du
media ag fait que ça non j'étais facteur
deux ou trois mois avant de déclarer ce
genre d' aventure et c'est pour ça que
j'ai écrit steve d'ailleurs parce que je
dois tellement à ce métier à la radio
j'ai adoré la radio ça ça fait de moi
l'homme le plus chanceux du monde cergy
j'ai voyagé j'ai vu des trucs que
j'aurais jamais vu chez normand moi je
suis né dans un petit bled de normandie
qui joue les agriculteurs du dimanche je
suis devenu un agriculteur du dimanche
c'est pas du dimanche victor je passe
mon temps avec mes chevaux faire du foin
des des clôtures des trucs mais je suis
retourné à ma vie d'avant quand j'étais
petit mais entre temps j'ai eu la chance
de faire ce que j'avais envie de faire
enfin vous connaissez ça c'est ont fait
pas ce métier par hasard alors je disais
en présentant vous avez été dans la
dernière partie de la carrière président
de radio france c'est-à-dire président
de la première chaîne de service public
on va en parler et puis vous êtes devenu
un peu historiens avec ce livre là c'est
mon 2e saison de merveilleuses pour
commémorer je crois les 100 ans de la
radio et oui ça a démarré le 24 décembre
1921 radio tour eiffel les premières
émissions là on avait déjà fait des
petits essais de transmission de par tsf
mais là c'est ça a été la première fois
que ben on a envoyé un programme qu'on a
diffusé un programme je pense que
personne n'a entendu d'ailleurs parce
que pour entendre fallait un poste mais
bon ça s'est développé très très vite
dix ans après il y avait six millions de
récepteurs en france donc cet effort ni
d'appui à se développer partout et puis
c'est tellement génial d'entendre un
truc qui sort d'une boîte j'ai jamais
rien compris la technique non alors il
dans le bouquin me jean despas vécu nous
demandez rien sur la technique pour en
rien d'annoncé leçon moi qui m'intéresse
des voix qui l'intéressé c'est à dire je
trouve ça formidable moyen le contenu
oui ça c'est encore autre chose indien
cette magie pour moi de la voix je suis
très sensible aux voix et je pense que
c'est lié au fait que quand j'étais
petit gamin dans ma campagne normande ma
mère me disait tu peux pas t'ennuyer est
un chien et des livres mais y'avait que
la radio la grosse radio qu'on avait sur
le buffet à ça marchait toute la journée
ce truc dit on entendait des choses pour
quelqu'un qui a pas beaucoup de
perspectives même géographique enfin
c'était un truc absolument merveilleux
même les noms sur l'allée vous savez sur
les vieux récepteur il y avait écrit
bratislava ou greenwich qu'est ce que ça
veut dire ça les noms de stations ouais
et donc amusé un jour je vais aller à
greenwich québec mais je suis pas l'air
évidemment mais bratislava non plus chez
plus comment s'appelle aujourd'hui mais
enfin bref on a pu aller à ushuaïa oui
j'aurais cuba oui m'enfin ça c'était
quand même des prix assez loin mais
c'est quelque chose qui m'a toujours
inspiré enfin d'une espèce sam à
développer l'imagination comme et c'est
vrai pour il ya 40 millions de français
qui écoutent la radio tous les jours
le bouquin c'est quand même c'est un
bouquin d'histoire quoi avec plein
d'anecdotes il ya des petites histoires
mais au-delà de ça il ya la grande
histoire de l'information c'est la
grande histoire de la radio et puis
derrière les russes ont une histoire
politique on n'a pas les premiers ce
qu'on a est ce qu'on connaît l'inventeur
de la radio alors là vous me posez des
colts 500 dans le bouquin mais non mais
c'est dissone en gros le marconi oui on
m'a dit mahmoud ça se discute beaucoup
marconi oui mais edison lui il avait
découvert ça commence à marcher mais il
s'intéressait aux lampes envoyé au
courant électrique dans les lampes donc
la radio c'était pas il n'avait pas
projeté mais auparavant il y avait
quelqu'un qui avait découvert ont dû
inventer mais il avait découvert les
ronds les ondes radioélectriques
l'estuaire est ce que l'un des coups
voilà ça d'ailleurs on parle toujours de
résoudre siens de choses il s'est passé
plein de trucs très très vite qu'ils
n'ont pas été exploitées sur une
cinquantaine une soixantaine d'années
puis a toujours un type qui sait à quoi
ça peut servir une invention et ça c'est
absolument formidable pressé on doit
tellement à ces gens là imaginer la vie
sans radio et mon dieu mais kof d'accord
on a les réseaux sociaux d'internet
c'est pas tant mais c'est juste que là
que m'est même plus loin moi qui
reprends ma casquette de prof d'économie
que j'ai été autrefois c'est
l'innovation photo pépé rience à dire
c'est quelqu'un qui à vendre un produit
dont personne n'a besoin à priori oui
appris non mais c'est exactement ça et
alors il y avait un type qui avait très
bien compris ça c'était léopold le roi
des belges
oui parce que lui alors un avant les
français enfin avant radio tour eiffel
je crois que c'était en 1909 il avait
dit mais c'est génial là d'une austère
1914 mais c'est absolument génial et
donc il avait fait des concerts le
samedi donc le samedi bayh avait deux ou
trois heures de concert consacré sa
chronique avec des compositeurs français
et belges arrêt je connais pas très bien
les combos des belges mais ça fait rien
c'était quand même sympa paraît-il est
pareil je me demande qui pouvait bien
écouter ça donc le roi des belges
avaient compris qu'ils avaient peut-être
un avenir là dedans c'est formidable oui
alors il ya ya ya eu aussi quand on
regarde l'évolution des technologies et
ethniques
dd l'innovation qui ont été plus
nombreuses que dans l'automobile par
exemple qui sont pourtant deux produits
et de grandes inventions qui ont la même
origine la même époque je sais pas si la
comparaison tient mais parce que
regarder dans la radio
vous avez démarré les postes à galène
oui moi je jouais à ça quand j'étais
petit
la radio radio lallaoui alors ça c'est
des gros trucs a été lent tout ça
qu'après et résistant oui à bâle
transistors non parce qu'avant la radio
à rester où elle est et il fallait un
fils sont dits volts machin de
transistors c'est la libération de la
radio que c'est absolument phénoménal ce
qui s'est passé c'est un petit machin
transistors mais je vous dis qu dernière
j'ai regardé ce que c'est qu'un
transistors sa de petits bouts de fils
qui traînent c'est gros comme les hommes
la moitié d'un dé à coudre enfin à
l'époque et ça marche on peu baladé son
transistor à prendre mais dans la
voiture mais une antenne ça roule ça
marche c'est absolument c'est
indispensable quand je sais pas comment
on pourrait vivre sans radio chez moi je
te dis radioshack pièce
quel est le secret vous dites à un
moment le secret du succès de la radio
vous dit à la radio ne parle qu'à une
seule personne à la fois même si des
dizaines de millions de paires
d'oreilles traîne derrière leur poste
c'est vrai c'est une relation
extraordinaire c'est ma plus longue
disette à média chaud il aurait pu dire
ça média chaud mais il ya un type qu'a
compris sommes merveilleusement cyrus
welt franklin delano russe pendant la
dépression il faut imaginer ce que ça a
été dans les années 30 l'amérique
s'était c'était foutu crysis et
roosevelt n'avait rien à offrir comme
solution c'est comme aujourd'hui la
pandémie virus on peut pas régler les
choses comme ça on peut pas dire je
décrète que la dernière c'est fini donc
il n'avait qu'une un truc avant c'était
une idée est donc son idéal a pris 10
ans comme se concrétiser que ça aille
mieux il le faisait la radio ce décès
fameuse conversation au panache pinellas
il y en a fait une quarantaine il y
avait là il y avait 60 millions de gens
qui écoutent et chaque samedi c'est en
fait ce n'est pas chaque sable email un
samedi de temps en temps et la radio a
permis aux semelles de convaincre les
américains qu'il y avait un espoir et un
futur c'est quand même si vous à relais
quand une personne a eu c'est ça où on
va on est alors il était à moi j'ai
réécouté des certaines de ses émissions
cette extraordinaire ils utilisent peu
de mots c'est à dire dans le vocabulaire
anglais qu ces riches ils n'utilisent
que 800 mo parmi les plus quotidiens des
américains et par là chaque américain à
chaque citoyen et donc les gens étaient
faciles il a été élu quatre fois le
faire on n'a jamais battu le record donc
c'était un naturel c'est un homme qui
savait mais la radio a toujours eu un
rôle historique politique
dans les mouvements et dans les laits
période tendue pour le meilleur et pour
le pire d'ailleurs parce que si on était
un petit allemands dans les années 30 on
l'a beaucoup entendu hitler et ses potes
à la radio et puis c'était visite est
plutôt bon dans le genre pour mettre le
feu au coin des rues y avait une espèce
de talent de showman aussi ça me fait
mal de dire ça mais c'est comme ça mais
pétain c'est à la radio qu'il a dit il
faut baisser les armes et où le 17 juin
à bâle nord ça il n'a pas traîné et
c'est formidable sur écoute sa personne
entendue vers 50 ans du label donne un
peu de gens et très peu de gens ont
entendu mais mais quand on écoute le
truc enfin celui du lendemain d'ailleurs
bien la bbc a conservé celui du 19 quoi
c'est formidable que ça veut dire
on n'est pas morts on va continuer on va
en baver y aura du sang de la sueur et
des larmes mais c'est pas grave c'est le
destin de la france ça fout la chaire de
plus tard il ya eu les événements de 68
pour était quand même très très impacté
alors là la radio s'est fâché avec de
gaulle quand même c'est lara drijoka cas
contribué à fragiliser ce feu par
général favorisé les manifestations
route c'est drôle moi j'étais gamin
enfin j'ai que j'écoutais singer europe
parce que et rtl c'est parce que france
inter ça se tenait tranquille comme on
n'était pas antifrançais pas gauchiste
inter radio sens et la voix de son maire
monsieur parfait
veillez oui oui mais j'écoutais mon des
reportages des petits pas c'était
extraordinaire d'ailleurs j'ai eu envie
de
abba c'était comme s'ils étaient en
train de commenter un match de foot quoi
ça allait aussi vite il y avait de
l'émotion il ya le sage décision
il y avait de l'action tous les soirs on
s'ennuyait pas déjà
oui tomber sauvageau tous ces gens là
toutes les choses graves voilà j'ai
l'impression qu'on les apprend par la
radio ouais et en plus quand on écoute
la radio c'est si c'est grave ou si
c'est pas grave plus qu'à la télé mais
alors vous vous ravoux rappelé que au
moment des événements 68 quand le
général de gaulle j'aime bien est revenu
à des parties d'abord
bernard et il est rentré il a pris il a
parlé à la radio
alors plus ça prend une minute un son
speech je me retirerai pas voilà je dis
si l'assemblée
tous les gens qui vous parle sont des
menteurs ils veulent que vous imposez du
malheur terminé ça a duré une minute il
ya un million de personnes sur les
chances de viser une heure après c'est
fou quoi c j'essaie d'imaginer ça sur
une chaîne dawnnews aujourd'hui veut
c'est pas d'un contenu du jeu dissout
l'assemblée tout vive la france sait pas
ce qui je crois que c'est une impression
pas le contexte et on peut jamais qu'on
pourrait aller contexte mais ça
m'impressionne franchement il ya un
autre truc du général qui m'impressionne
c'est à dire je parle beaucoup général
mais il inaugure la maison de la radio
easter décembre 63 et donc d'où le titre
du livre faut-il la saison de
merveilleuses une maison à l'évidence
ivre il met enfin - ca c c'est un
discours d'une page donc géo lu
attentivement ce ce extraordinaire se
dire c'était de l'âme le plus
modernistes punk du monde quand il parle
de la radio j'ai jamais vu ça et donc
cinquante ans après je suis pdg de la
maison on est en plein travaux au sein
un souk la maison de la radio et donc je
vois françois hollande président la
république et je dis monsieur le
président ce serait sympa pour le 51 la
maison de la radio de venir
du oui et puis je dis je me conseille
quand même de lire avant le discours du
général de gaulle ça me prend qu'une
page vous verrez c'est tu sais pas s'il
a lui mais je crois pas parce que
c'était nettement moins lyrique le
speech de françois hollande je me
dispute est un peu déçu mais bon un
utérus t c'est gentil est reparti
aussitôt d'ailleurs parce que j'ai plus
pourquoi pour quelles raisons mais enfin
quelque chose avait déplu mais il n'y
avait pas atteindre le
lyrique alors il vous très important
pour le général de gaulle maison de la
radio sa situation géographique
puisqu'on est dans les grandes voix on
va y revenir à mais on va s'arrêter
quelques minutes et puis on se retrouve
dans un instant sur le plateau de la
grande interview
[Musique]
bien on se retrouve sur le plateau de la
grande interview avec jean luc hess qui
nous inondent d'anecdotes sur la la la
radio puisqu'il y a passé sa nuit 1
terminant président de radio france
toute sa vie pratiquement dans le
service public n'est pas mis le pied sur
une radio privée c'est sur radio
classique radio classique j'ai été
remercié un jour de france inter va
acheter directeur moi j'ai trouvé un
point de chute super u des gens sympas
puis j'ai appris plein de choses parce
que moi j'étais plutôt aux canaux les
puits bruce springsteen donc j'ai appris
un peu des choses quand ça mes amis de
radio classique c'est un très bon
souvenir sauf que c'était une radio
canadienne et thématiques csp + wii très
chic et moi je t'aime une rechute sauf
que moi j'étais habitué aux coups aux
grosses machines où on dit tiens on va
aller à new york on et 150 ont offert
deux journées spéciales on va là berlin
valent à moscou donc là c'était plus
confiné mais j'en garde un excellent
souvenir alors vous raconter tout ça
dans saison merveilleuse le livre que
vous sortez la radio à 100 ans et chez
baker street on n'avait pas cité le nom
de l'éditeur faut toujours de l'éditeur
ou trapattoni temps évidemment
donc c'est une oeuvre d'historien mais
vous vous raconter aussi à côté de la
technique l'évolution tout ça quand on
convient de voir les grandes voix les
voies ce qui ont parce que la radio
c'est surtout des voix jeunes et moins
jeunes des douanes mais il ya quand même
eu beaucoup plus d'hommes que de femmes
quand je fais le décompte de tout ce que
vous racontez je ne suis plus urgents de
la shinra les quotas ne sont pas
respectées il ya un changement fin que
le monde change les grandes voix sur
devenu célébrissime dans la france
entière la famille duraton enfin c'était
toute ma petite enfance à vous aussi
sûrement vrai mais je suis tout double
oui c'était pas c'était pas sur radio
france sur ses terres théâtre mais
toutes les radios importe énormément
europe 1 mme auger biberonné europe 1
quand j'étais gamin mais même
tardivement rtl aussi et france inter
bon c'est devenu ma maison voilà deux
c'était mon on y à moi mais mes jeux en
fait j'écris steve parce que je dois
tellement à tous ces gens là tous les
gens pleins je vais pas citer tout le
monde prend le tribunal des flagrants
délires il claude bolling dernier en
illustration
je dois tout à ces gens là parce que des
heureux ils m'ont c'est pas apprendre
quelque chose s'est montré quelque chose
c'est quand vous avez du temps josé
artur aujourd'hui ce faire bouteiller
chancel voilà quoi si vous regardez ça
vous êtes invités à regarder comment
fonctionne l'esprit de gens qui ont
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de talent et
de culture c'est ce qui me fascinait
vraiment soit lave portrait de josé
artur j'ai passé des années à rire avec
josé apprendre plein de trucs c'était un
homme extrêmement cultivé type descender
mission le soir qui les adversaires en
danger nos études
record
battu on a tous vu d'abord on a même vu
les beatles d'aubarne à la maison de la
radio offaly tout le monde y est passé
j'ai jamais vu un type qui avait refusé
une invitation de josé pourtant il avait
la dent dure quand ici n'était pas c'est
très tard le soir en recevant deux
heures me 9 heures salle d'écouté y
avait quelques
mois voilà moi je suis admiratif de ces
gens mais j'ai travaillé avec bouteiller
par exemple je t'aime petit reporter
effectif est trop lent sur la photo la
peinture jouer s'étirer volant avec un
travail aussi eu ainsi retourner dame
qui a travaillé pourtant je suis pas
sportif mais lui il aime bien lui vendre
giza nov mais bon flins dieu dieu ait
son âme mais bouteiller un jour je
t'aime petit reporter à la rédaction de
france inter où je m'ennuie est quand
même assez régulièrement parce que
c'était répétitif faire les flashs tout
ça c'est des bons et me dit tu veux
aller au festival de juan les pins avec
moi mais comment je veux on va les voir
la fiche gerald karl bézy et tout mais
c'est dingue quoi genève 22 23 ans tous
ces gens là m'ont apporté claude villers
il m'a dit tu veilles aux états unis
avec moi accompagné des gens mais baie
comeau mais comment donc monseigneur
donc tous ces gens appuient les regarder
travailler d'irak je récitais c'est
gérard cyr qu'était le gentleman absolue
complice de jean yanne pour tout un tas
de films il était inspecteur des impôts
quand même au départ c'est tous ces gens
ont eu un chemin de vie extraordinaire
je trouve ceci est vraiment un profil de
carrière d'un les écoles de jeunesse y
en avait mais bon ce n'est pas tellement
le truc et il y avait alors si c'est un
peu monsieur la marlière d'un vieux
machins si je dis ça mais je trouve que
tous ces gens avaient vu claude villers
avait été catcheur pour gagner sa vie il
avait travaillé au crédit lyonnais à
l'âge de 15 ans avec eddy mitchell il
était potes que blocher d'ailleurs si
c'est eux qui faisaient la radio web
puis 20 puis avec une grande liberté
contrairement l'époque politiquement
était pas évident sous pompidou moi je
suis en dresse une compil où s'étaient
pas mais ce qui a changé c'est quand
même l'ouverture à la concurrence après
mai 68 l'arrivée des arrivées des
périphériques comme les officiers alors
elle était déjà là était périphérique
vraiment oui mais sont restés
périphériques et puis il ya eu toute la
modulation de fréquence oui mais fm
radio libre non ça c'est à 80 ça c'est
mitterrand temps longtemps après oui
mais ça on lui doit sa mort a explosé il
y avait beaucoup de robinet à musique
aussi et puis avait c'est pour ça je
suis tant attaché au service public moi
j'ai commencé à travailler à fip les fip
c'était d'être des jolies filles qui
faisait la circulation la météo et les
infos culture sur une toute petite
fréquence parisienne 514 ont de moyenne
ça dit rien à personne personne c'est ce
que ces questions de moyenne - non plus
mais donc il y avait une espèce de
liberté aussi appuyé de de
co2 et garito les producteurs étaient
très difficiles sur la qualité des de la
musique sur la qualité du propos sur la
qualité des voix on y revient toujours
aux voies et sage c'est pour ça que je
suis très attachée au strict il y avait
il ya toujours cette espèce de souci
tout de même du contenu de cette
liberté-là a été un facteur de liberté
pour l'opinion publique qui s'est
émancipé d'un certain nombre de pouvoirs
et des oiseaux lpo notamment à
l'étranger on l'a vu dans tous les pays
de l'est par exemple vous l'a commencé à
bouger avec les radios oui de l'occident
en france cette année en france
particulier parce que alors
souvenez-vous france inter le rtf c'est
la voix de la france
au fil
des gaules et moi je n'ai pas de mots
allez chiche à l'aise j'ai souvenir de
la mort de pompidou beau c'était un peu
compliqué quand on est mature force
politique nouvelle en parle on en
parlait les diamants de giscard on n'a
pas beaucoup parlé quand j'ai annoncé la
candidature de coluche au journal de 8
heures du matin on m'a prié de les faire
autre chose puis d'aller faire les
flashs donné quoi c'était quand même et
ça s'est libéralisé très tardivement
quand même très tardivement
mais ça a été sous tutelle très forte
oui
ça se traduise et comment parce que vous
étiez vous dites dans livres je crois en
tant président de radio france on m'a
jamais téléphoné pour me dire quoi que
ce soit tout d'abord faute de faux
pas si c'est vrai je vous jure c'est
vrai il m'est arrivé de m'engueuler avec
un ministre notamment ma ministre de
tutelle ouais ça m'est arrivé très
fortement j'ai des souvenirs très précis
mais qu'est ce qu'on pouvait me faire
j'avais après tout est élu par le csa
l'assemblée le sénat lui rappelant les
propositions de nicolas sarkozy donc on
pouvait difficilement me renvoyer et
puis qui va mettre une rédaction à gino
de nos jours franchement qui va
compliquer au pouvoir mais c'est pas
compliqué c'est mission impossible
c'est normal car on peut même on est un
pays moderne enfin sperian à se
pardonner mon avis et je vais dire
peut-être une énormité de journalistes
retouches journalistes quand vous avez
été nommé vous a été nommé en toute
connaissance de cause on savait bien
qu'il n'était pas un fou furieux quand
même nom nord mais en plus elle
responsabilités correspond chez il avait
côtoyé
quand on veut noyer son chien on savait
ce pc enfin bon pipe api quand on
accepte le jazz on sait à quoi on
s'expose notre ami harry truman disait
quand on n'aime pas la chaleur on va pas
dans la cuisine il avait bien raison on
sait le deuxième jour que ça va être
comme ça pendant cinq ans et puis ça a
été comme ça pendant cinq ans et puis
c'est des maisons où les gens enfin je
parle de ce que je connais simplement un
mais la maison de radio france on fout
pas les genres n'importe quoi il faut
vraiment en faire quel regard vous
portez aujourd'hui sur le fonctionnement
du service public de la radio et de la
télévision d'ailleurs c'est une question
compliquée mais un trop sec et pas ce
truc bien sûr un bon temps mais j'étais
jamais de mal de la maison que mick
jagger du mal de la maison mais vous
pouvez voir un jugement chez lipp il
j'ai de temps en temps quelques
agacements où est ce que je veux dire
ouais là mais j'ai des agacements si
quand je regarde certaines chaînes aux
news que j'écoute de tout chez news dans
votre ciel d'information continue
c'est nous tous à une série de très gros
agacement aussi et puis je conçois que
quand on écoute on va dire france inter
au hasard présente qu'on puisse avoir
quelques crispations si on n'est pas
orientée dans un certain sens mais pour
moi l'arbitré des élégances c'est
l'auditeur comme par hasard france au
recteur et la première vient l animateur
qui vous a donné du fil à recoudre
reconnaît daniel mermet nous est tout à
fait d'excellents producteurs de radio
autre excellent producteur de radio des
dents sur les bons sens et qu'il a
provoquées mais on sait par des moines
la grossièreté mais engueuler comme des
chiens pendant des années et puis je
devais toujours conservé à l'antenne
parce que je pensais que cette pensée
marxiste enfin les opprimer le peuple
machin bon peut-être que ça existe dans
ses fantasmes nous on vit en france on
vit pas je sais pas vous mais dont j'ai
toujours pensé que même ça me plaisait
pas cette parole avait le droit
d'exister sur le service public
d'ailleurs alors je dis les conflits en
a eu et puis des par exemple à de
sévères faut pas pousser non plus faut
battre me chercher
mais mais je regrette pas je regrette
pas d'avoir laissé une place dans les
années à ce genre de pensée qui sont
très loin de des miennes quoi et en plus
il faisait beaucoup d'auditeurs à une
heure où il ya personne qui écoute la
radio à 3 heures d'après midi un
[Musique]
peu je me souviens très bien s'en sont
sans rapport me rapporter des souvenirs
personnels j'étais un peu sa tête de
turc parfois d'ailleurs mais ça se
mérite cette tête de turc et d'ailleurs
je profite de cet instant pour pour vous
rendre hommage m'aviez nous aviez mis en
relation avec bernard maris ce notre
confrère de charlie hebdo
malheureusement qui disparut dans cette
épouvantable attentats et on a tenu
ça marchait bien comment ça marchait
bien on s'entend début à la fin on
certains des 13e et d'un bep trop bien
des noms mais c'est moi je pense que
tout ce qui est excessif est
insignifiant way est donc bon on peut
vivre avec l'insignifiance mais je
conçois que ça puisse agacer l'autre
soir le pied côté inquisiteur mais ça
c'est une dérive du métier c'est pas
simplement une d'erik en fou quand vous
essayez là le monde journalistique
français avec le monde américain que
vous connaissez bien d'accord suis
rentré des états unis j'ai passé dix ans
et on m'a nommé directeur adjoint de la
rédaction de france inter et j'ai fait
une dépression nerveuse quoi j'allais la
conférence de rédaction je m'ennuie à
mourir je me disais mais je demandais au
chalut seas politique qu'est ce que tu
as aujourd'hui pour le jean est très
bien mais on a le conseil des ministres
on est mercredi juste heures merci jeu
c'était un peu d un jour je leur ai dit
je m'ennuie je vais m'endormir je me
suis endormi j'ai eu du mal après
resterez d un lien amical avec la
rédaction mais depuis ça m'est passé
mais comment comment vous jugez
aujourd'hui le fait qu' un certain
nombre de journalistes semblent s'est
octroyé un pouvoir de juger un pouvoir
même deux condamnés qui des sachets de
loin leur procès me choque infiniment au
chat à ça me choque c'est le contraire
de l'an passé et comment réguler mais je
sais pas c'est un vrai souci parce que
le ravissement de soi même c'est pas une
fin en soi que j'ai pas choisi de faire
ce métier pour être un inquisiteur je
déteste
ça ah bah c'est une bonne question tiens
je vais poser la question au csa
d'ailleurs j'ai déjà posé et j'ai pas de
réponses très précises je crois que ça
extrêmement dangereux c'est que ça
malsain d'abord puis moralement c'est
indéfendable mais c'est extrêmement
dangereux parce que moi j'aime savoir
d'où parle les gens je suis journaliste
je suis pas médecin je suis pas
enquêteur ne peut l'insup âgées jamais
joué ce rôle là dans ma vie j'ai cherché
j'ai essayé de trouver des réponses mais
l étrave ainsi jamais à oger d'une
qualité ou une compétence ou une
expertise que je n'avais pas et souvent
mes os écorche quand j'entends ce qu'il
faut en penser ça me semble absolument
c'est pas dérisoire en plus c'est
dangereux pour la suite je pense que
notre métier devrait un peu
l'autocritique ça sert toujours mais
devrait un peu douté de ses bases et des
revoir et les remettre en question
remettre en cause je vous prendre de la
distance par rapport à twitter fléchi
par rapport aux réseaux sociaux par
rapport aux 10 que va permettre le
diable dans sa boîte et puis après tout
il faut aussi se méfier de nos réactions
moi je fais un certain âge j'ai mon
expérience le monde a changé donc
j'essaie de bien bien comprendre le tout
j'ai parfois du mal j'ai parfois du mal
c'est toujours pensé et encore vous êtes
peut-être parce que si on veut un peu le
comprendre un peu mieux et puis voir ce
qui s'est passé pendant un siècle quand
même dans son de la radio je rappelle ça
s'appelle les urnes merveilleuse le
livre la radio assange en caisse bakar
ce prix je rappelle que vous étiez
président de radio france vous avez même
été membre du comité éthique lors de
cette chan au nom de ce qu'on vient
d'évoquer c'est à dire la liberté
d'expression c'est pas un truc ou
condamnent sans connaître sans savoir et
dont j'ai eu plaisir même un honneur à
présider ce comité d'éthique et ça c'est
plutôt bien s'est jetée ça a été un
plaisir de vous recevoir en patience
aujourd'hui de rappeler à terme de
souvenirs pour une petite partie toute
petite partie des communes à nous est
commune je regarde moi même un excellent
souvenir et je garderai un bon souvenir
de cette démission bah déterminer quand
les caisses on la retrouve en
rediffusion la retrouve en replay aussi
sur les réseaux sociaux qui diffusa
radio on la retrouve sur le site
internet arte france point tv merci à
tous à très bientôt
[Musique]